bring it on one night Willie
[Music]
who your bullets they're really fast
Deadpool 2 is up against the ventures of
pretty war to be a big box office battle
if you could pick any avenger to watch
kick Deadpool's ass oh she would say
that again if i can you pick an avenger
to kick Deadpool's ass oh really yeah
oh man who would be good who would be
good Scott oh I have one of the women
one of the women either Scarlet Witch
which is Lizzy Olson or Scarlett
Johansson just cuz I I would like to
have his ass kicked by a woman for sure
no you know cable turns back time in
this movie yeah if you could turn back
time change anything about any role
you've ever done oh good
that's better cool what would you what
would you do John axe yeah I'd go back I
can more if I'd morph into an eraser
there's a race it race Jonah Hex I was
how what's the weirdest way that you
promote that you prepared for this movie
never focused so much on cosmetics body
and the sculpting and all that kind of
stuff and working out like I've always
kind of done interior working out and it
was fun you know creating the the scar
and all that kind of stuff so when I saw
dave bautista and gold's gym the mecca
and he was like whoa what happened to
you that was that's when I knew I was on
the right track and if you could give
yourself a mutant power what would it be
the ability to turn into an eraser he's
Jonah I don't feel that really that way
about Jonah eggs but I just like the way
it sounds and what do you hope audiences
take away from this movie entertainment
you know and in me and I think it's fun
it's funny it's a great breath of fresh
air within all that not necessarily the
seriousness but the grand kind of
presentation that Marvel movies are you
know and this is just kind of this
irreverent bastard stepchild that's just
like I you know this kid in an aisle in
a grocery store that's just freaking out
that's Ryan Reynolds all over it you
know you know there's a fun say anything
moment in this film went you know when
they hold up the radio and there's a
song blaring what song do you go to to
kind of say win somebody over win
somebody back the song from Tootsie that
was a good song I played that for a girl
when I was 14 years old
really I took the fun yeah I was awful
man well what did you see like ran hung
up the phone and that wasn't enough so
you didn't just I did it was I had I had
a you know a record player and I took it
and I remember I remember the song it
was awful
I did not win her over with that song no
a lot of people calling this the summer
of Josh Brolin you have four films over
four consecutive months and what's
interesting you you play kind of
devastating characters destructive
characters and or more of them who do
you thinks the most destructive
destructive is definitely Thanos the
Annis is a great destructive character
who has the right intentions just the
wrong manifestations of that intention I
like that character a lot and there was
a really fun characters a fun movie to
do yeah but you know destructive
character yeah I guess they are you know
I mean there's I know that there was a
moment of like I want to find this type
of thing to do and I found it and even
though it's over a two-and-a-half year
period it's all coming out within four
months except for only the bribe which
is really weird
who will you think would be wind between
Thanos and cable you know what people
have asked that if like Vanna it's so
funny even to answer this question with
any kind of seriousness whatsoever but
if Thanos didn't have which I didn't
think about if he didn't have the
gauntlet then it would be more of an
even tete-a-tete I think but Thanos for
sure when Thanos snapped his finger did
josh brolin live or die I lived
obviously I'm here with you I survived I
was one of the I was one of the few
[Music]
meats that love domino I'm lucky luck
isn't a superpower yes it is let's meet
in the middle and say no it is so if you
could pick any Avenger and watch that
Avenger kick Deadpool's ass who would it
be
tennis huh for me it wouldn't be famous
it would be like like the weakest
character and like oh yeah you know but
you know ant-man you know was friend but
that Michael Payne okay I would love cuz
like no powers at all super funny I
loved him in that movie so yeah what is
the most the weirdest way or the most
unconventional way that you prepared for
this movie I had a I had a coach um just
to help me get into character he's a
very angry character
so what we did I'm he got all these like
these balls and the coach would stand in
front of the concrete mornings like I
mentioned these are fireballs okay so
I'd carry them using both him at me and
you were just like pick me off and I'll
just throw them at him and you come on
you're hurting me and he was quite a
twig like he's kinda skinny so just like
like body roll and move out of the way
and I would just throw him on the ground
saw just fire them at him and it was
cervical that's cool I don't know if
this is weird but I like almost every
day before shooting and my boyfriend is
an actor too and it called movie like
alright I have to do this scene like
what should I do you know how could I
you know how I tried this why I'd like
write down different alts in different
ways of like interpreting different
things and we talked about like oh yeah
it'd be it'd be funny to approach this
way or that way but I would like talk
through every scene with him and we
would like conclusively together like
come up with a conclusion on like on how
on a good way to approach it
well that's good could you want to go
that was a good thing like same with an
Jamaica with it
yeah would what you want to go do the
same with an idea voice yeah yeah you
can't go in blind and I think that's the
thing is like that's what we're like
directing comes in is right you think
you think the directors making sure
everybody's making the same movie so you
come in with your own interpretation and
stuff then they guide you into like well
they mold Isis the world yeah and I mean
I'm the first to say like I
need a director like I think I can take
a note like a champ but I like the
guidance just too what more but like
what do you mean by doing like do it
bigger what do you mean what do and if
you could give yourself a mutant power
what would it be
I'm happy with fire but I would really
like something when I can't water first
water you could pick any Avenger who
would you want to watch kick their
that's a loaded question that's a loaded
question I'm sure there's a lot of
people that you know would have a
particular choice I don't know
I think I'd like to see Hawkeye kick
Deadpool's ass what's the weirdest way
that you prepared for this movie like
anything unconventional that you did
yeah I mean I think prepared it's not
super unconventional but it's what I do
we created a music song list Ryan
started it and he had a lot of songs
already logged on it and then we started
to share songs on it and I sort of like
try to get the soundtrack of the movie I
had done that with atomic blonde but it
was just me that was really interesting
like getting into his headspace about
the tone and like what he thought for
this moment and like why subversive
track works here and why a sincere track
works there and so that process was I
mean invaluable and and helped us keep
the tone of the movie just right you
know there's a fun say anything moment I
know much to that moving up the radio
like if you could pick a song that you
would hold up to kind of win somebody
back or win somebody over what song
Chicago it's hard to say I'm sorry maybe
you know that might be it yeah that was
actually in the running for a while and
you know I mean the Peter Gabriel is
obviously the classic total nod yeah but
Chicago hard to say I'm sorry you know
you know my love was meant to be if you
could give yourself a mutant power
I want Domino's power that's luck is the
best right I just want to walk out that
door walk across the street have two
cars miss me yep go up to the coffee
shop somebody hands me a latte like it's
just luck right on and what do you hope
audiences take away from this movie I
mean talking about the great time that
they had actually really and I always
say this I hope they take home sort of
the moral message and I guess it's hard
to say it's a moral message do you know
Deadpool shoots everybody how could
there be a moral message and I'm like
there is a moral message I mean he is
trying to do the right thing and what
he's trying to do is show this kid some
kindness and a world that has oppressed
this kid and by showing that kid
kindness he stops his kid from being you
know something bad and that's like a
huge huge moral lesson that maybe we
could sort of take you times up dumbass
well that's just lazy writing so how
much the description when Josh Brolin
came on board knowing that he was
playing Thanos uh we we wrote a couple
Thanos jokes just because we figured we
should make a nod to it we hadn't seen
Avengers oh so we didn't really know
what we were up against and Thanos is a
tremendously awesome character it didn't
change too much like this structure was
the same we obviously changed the
character Josh's voice and his strengths
and and how he's able to emote so much
without saying anything like just on his
face so that helped you know and
speaking of kind of writing jokes like
that how fluid is the script what you
know current references it's so fluid I
mean it's so fluid that the brown
Panther joke was three weeks ago three
weeks ago really yeah I mean the great
thing is he's in a mask so we can put
words into his mouth up until we lock
picture so we it is a constantly
evolving you know joke machine you know
from from the very start of the process
which was on this movie June of 2015 all
the way up to two weeks ago so and do
you have a specific process in terms of
like mapping out the story the action
the jokes you do it all at the same time
well you generally work on structure and
story first so you get an outline to
where you know what's gonna happen and
every scene in what order and then you
start to fill in the actual screenplay
pages and then the jokes are the last
thing that are changing you know and
they can change on the day and again
even even as recently as a couple weeks
ago so it's it's big blocks first little
blocks later structure generally once
you've built the foundation that
hopefully never changes from you know
conception all the way to screen because
if that changes you start getting into
big trouble and was there anything too
hot too hot to handle that they're like
guys we cut Disney joke we wrote one
Disney joke once we found out the merger
was gonna happen and it didn't it was
actually oh no were the merger was gonna
have died because of them where that's
exactly right now and I think it was we
didn't want to bring down a
multi-billion dollar corporate merger
with one silly joke so we didn't want
Robert Iger and Rupert Murdoch to be
chasing us down the center do you think
Deadpool could exist in that in that
post absolutely I think he will exist
there's no doubt about it and how hard
is it for you now giving up sort of your
baby because they're doing the x-force
movie yeah it's it's going out in the
world well I mean our hope is that we'll
be working on Deadpool 3 while they're
doing x-force or getting it ready so
that was we were gonna stagger these
things out but but it's in great hands
with regards so we're excited and last
but not least Peter
any power want to tell us about you no I
don't have one
I just saw the ad you're in